a judge has removed pop star britney
spears father as her court appointed
guardian after 13 years after spears
accused him of years of abuse a
temporary guardian has been appointed in
his place fans of the pop star have long
been campaigning for an end to the legal
arrangement
[Music]
[Applause]
jubilation and relief outside a los
angeles court the victory for britney
spears is also a triumph for her fans
and their free britney campaign
my heart's racing out of my chest
it's so bad i'm so excited for her i'm
so excited for what she has to do with
the rest of her life
britney spears has been living under a
court appointed conservatorship since
she suffered a mental breakdown 13 years
ago
it gave her father jamie spears control
not only over her 60 million dollar
estate but also extensive aspects of her
personal life including visitors and
medical decisions
jamie spears stepped aside from part of
the conservatorship in 2019 but he
stayed in charge of her finances
on thursday judge brenda penny ended
that control she suspended jaime spears
from the conservatorship calling it a
toxic environment
the singer's lawyer said that jamie
spears had spied on his daughter's
intimate conversations including with
her children and her boyfriend
[Music]
britney spears has been faced
with a decade-long nightmare a cuff
gasket nightmare orchestrated by her
father
and others
the attorney said the years-long
campaign by fans had been instrumental
[Applause]
public support swelled after several
documentaries and after britney spears
spoke out herself telling the court the
arrangement was abusive and humiliating
for now the conservatorship remains in
place with an accountant replacing
britney's father
[Music]
[Applause]
but she could be freed from court
control entirely in a few weeks judge
penny will decide whether to end the
conservatorship at a future hearing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]